and it's tough man like we took the
precautions before we sat down you know
and that's the way i'm doing now like i
got eight tests in my backpack you know
each test kit got two if i see someone
they gotta take a test i think it is the
best most responsible thing to do
whether it's accurate or not it's a good
piece of mind because we can't treat
people like journalists man it's just
like it's getting weird so for me that's
been the best like now that the tests
are more available at walgreens and
whatnot i've been able to move around a
little more um but yeah kovu was rough
bro and i just bought a house in the
cuts and just chilled out for as long as
i could and
i think that like it really like let
people understand life is precious and
you got to pick your circles you know
what i mean yeah you've been extremely
cautious with with uh with the cove [ __ ]
a lot more cautious than some of your
counterparts maybe in the hip-hop game
right like what what's the motivation
behind that i mean my uncles died from
me two of them and like you know i look
at my text every other day to remind
myself you know he was just fine like me
and you were
and then was like i'm going to hospital
and then from the hospital's like yo
they're going to put me on this machine
and die and so it's like it happens like
that you know what i mean and so
i've seen a lot of people struggle for
it and i think that people that lost
people to cove it hits a little harder
it's home yeah my grandma died man
exactly and so like you know i've just
been bro i'm always been paranoid though
bro that's why you know i'm always
worried that's why i've never been you
know
never been to jail i never i've always
moved a certain way and i think that's
what got me where i'm at bro it's just
being cautious but at the same time like
i understand you still got to move you
know i mean so just move right